so what I want you to do is to consider
an astronaut all right now this
astronaut in his / her spaceship is is
traveling on an impressive speed as you
can see one of the tricky things about
being an astronaut being in the space is
that you miss what we're use to work out
how fast you're going right because if
you're in a car and you're hurtling
along the highway then what the scenery
around you is moving yes you're like I
have a sensation of going faster I have
a sensation of going slow and I can see
you know things around me changing I can
I can know oh I was I was in cherrybrook
and now I'm in the city it took me an
hour so I've traveled this fast right an
astronaut has no such thing does not
know what the phrase is by the way the
thing that they're missing that we have
that that they can't that pops them up
and be unable to tell ya a frame of
reference that's exactly what it's
called when you're out in space right
especially when you're out in like
proper space everything is just it's all
just black murkiness right no no planets
or other things nearby cuz space is big
so pro astronaut here has got no frame
of reference the outside information to
be able to say how fast how fast am I
going right by Bucky around and how far
am I going right but of course you know
it's a it's of rockets of course
instrumentation okay
so let's suppose the astronaut does know
how fast it's going how fast he or she
is going based on you know putting out
selling out of thrust knows how much
that thrust is compared to the mass of
the the spaceship and so knows its
velocity at any given time so let's just
shut that down for a second if the
velocity is known but nothing else is
known but there no mark is out there in
space so it's like you know you are
entering the the m2 and you get off the
m2 and then you know how far you've got
right if you have known velocity and
unknown displacement what do we do with
this okay now I put this out because
what we've been doing so far in calculus
has been the reverse of this right we
know some kind of quantity like a
position or how much water is in
a tank or something like that and we
want to work out from that how is that
changing right and velocity is just how
displacement is changing over time yeah
so velocity / speed I'm just going to
lump them together for now things like
say kilometers per hour kilometers per
hour that is a change in displacement or
position compared to a change in time
right so for example if I said 60
kilometers per hour as a velocity that
means that for every hour that I change
I change 60 kilometers in terms of
distance right so this is kind of like a
gradient we know how to find this thing
we don't have a fired velocity we
differentiate to find that right but
what if we don't know the thing to
differentiate to get to here how do we
come back to this okay so what we're
going to do is let's imagine an actual
concrete situation so we can get a
visual on what is happening okay I'm
going to give you some some silly
numbers there are more car related
numbers because got a better sense of
what they're like just because you know
these guys are traveling at whatever
tens of kilometres per per minute or
something like that something really
crazy so let's try and break it down a
little bit so if for example said rocket
is going at 60 kilometers per hour for
two hours for the first two hours of
their journey yes it's a very slow
rocket I don't know he gets motion
sickness or so about that so it's taking
it easy okay and then thereafter travels
at 100 kilometers per hour okay so just
imagine what's happening hitting along
lifts off from the launch pad is
traveling at that speed for exactly two
hours and then after that you know fires
the boosters of your and goes faster for
the rest of their journey okay
now what would this actually look like
we can draw a graph of this if for
instance we said we imagine starting our
journey at position zero and time zero
let's give some names to these things so
let's say this displacement right let's
call it f of X okay so I've got f of X
on my vertical axis and I've got X over
here
what does this placement depend on well
it's something based on time doesn't if
we want to work out something about this
we need to work out how long we've been
doing everything so let's call that time
the horizontal axis and we'll call this
guy displacement okay
let's consider the first two hours of
this journey we'll worry about the
change in speed of it later on
what is this graph going to look like if
we start at Ground Zero okay then here
we are at zero displacement and zero
time okay and then in the blink of an
eye we're traveling at 60 kilometers per
hour what does that graph look like
if the speed doesn't change they're
getting further and further away from
where they started so it's going to go
up and the speed isn't changing but the
speed is kind of like a well if it's the
derivative it's the gradient isn't it
right so the gradient isn't changing it
just stays it's 60 okay so let me draw
something that looks like that there you
go stays at 60 this is for one hours two
hours there we go will you put some
information on here let's suppose I want
to work out where have we ended where
are we what is the displacement after
that amount of time it's going to be
after two hours hundred twenty right now
just pause for a minute and think about
how you did that right because I haven't
given you a displacement function I
haven't told you what the equation of
this thing is but you inferred what
would happen here based on unknown
velocity does that make sense you know
how fast you're going you know it's not
changing so that gives you a straight
line and you can work out this number by
saying well - lots of 60 will give me
120 said okay so far so good but then
the rocket changes speed it increases
speed dramatically right so therefore
I'm going to have what a piece new
function right it's going to change its
gradient it won't be 60 anymore it'll be
a hundred does that make sense so what's
that gonna look like on my graph
yeah it's steeper that's exactly right
so instead of just like this it might be
something like that right except he's
started from 120 kilometers away from
where he began so something that looks
like maybe this is that okay you can see
it's deeper now I want to emphasize
again you do not know what this
displacement is you don't know what any
of these equations are but you are
inferring what is happening based on
these known velocities does that make
sense okay so now I'm going to pose a
question to you and we can work it all
out just from we can work out the answer
that is just from all of the numbers
that are on here okay the question is
how far does the astronaut travel from
the first hour to the third hour this
chunk of time in here let's just suppose
is he's not interested in the first hour
she's not interesting that first hour
what I'm interested in is this spot here
how far is it from that spot to that
spot there from the first hour to the
third hour that make sense so the
question is from the time at one hour
till the time three hours color how far
does the astronaut travel a more
technical way to say that is what's the
displacement over the course of that
interval okay now you can help me work
this out country how am I going to find
out how far the astronaut travels given
all this information knowing velocity
that I'm trying to work out something
that displacement when I don't even know
what the function is what are we going
to do any questions
let me ask this question again but with
a preface if you were in year 7 and I
gave you this information and this
question with no graph no nothing it
could work it out
couldn't you how far is traveled if you
don't know how far you travel from A to
B you just need to know where a is and
where B is don't you and then the
distance is just the difference between
those ok will you already know how far
you're going to be here don't you how
far you going to be when x equals 1 this
is going to be 60 okay and you inferred
that from the velocity because that's
known right hmm they have to think for a
little bit you're at 60 here this is our
starting point that we're considering
for that where are we going to end
figure out what happens from our 2 to
our 3 how fast is the astronaut
travelling she's traveling I'm gonna
come to that answer a second how fast is
he she family she's traveling at 100
kilometers per hour right so they're
starting at 120 at that point and then
they go 100 kilometers per hour per hour
for one hour
yeah which lands and therefore at 220 is
that ok that's where I've ended up first
leg of their journey second leg of the
journey here's my distance and I'm going
to mark that in if you're another color
it'll be useful use the suspect the
total distance is just I need another
marker here so from A to B you just go
distance to be take away the distance to
a that guy there right now before we
write down what that number is I want
you to see how we calculate it if my
function here this weird piece B of
function that I don't even know what it
is right if it's equal to 220 there it's
I'm interested in that value because its
F of 3 do you see that that's where I am
x equals 3 the Y value will be F of 3 is
that okay
I should say the vertical coordinate
because there actually is no Y on here
ok and then what I subtract to get the
difference is this
value but what's that F of F of one
because that's my starting point is that
okay is that right that of course is 220
take away 60 so it is 160 that's the
answer
right how far does your travel it's a
hundred zc colors not complicated okay